[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
it's based on georgia martin's book fire
and blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhaenyra targaryen's son
aegon iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the prequel will be the
dance of the dragon
a targaryen civil war it's been
confirmed that english actor patty
considine will starring the prequel as
king viserys the first targaryen
a key figure from prelude to the dance
of the dragons
the official description of the
character released by hbo describes him
king viserys targaryen is chosen by the
lords of westeros to succeed the old
king
jaehaerys targaryen at the great council
at harrenhal
a warm kind and decent man viserys only
wishes to carry forward his
grandfather's legacy
but good men don't necessarily make for
great kings
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens
brothers fought brothers dragons fought
the dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population
ultimately leading to their extinction
within a few decades
they never truly recovered by the end of
the reign of king viserys first
targaryen 20 dragons were alive
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid 131 ac
one of the main characters in this
series is going to be king viserys the
first targaryen
or at least in season 1 until he dies
and his death starts the targaryen civil
war
house of the dragon will not jump
straight into the fighting but will
rather start with the build up towards
it
towards the dance of the dragons it will
start with king uzares the first on his
reign
he'll live long enough for the series to
introduce us to all the main characters
they're going to be important in the
targaryen civil war and which side they
support as the future heir
as well as to set up all the animosity
at the court viserys the first targaryen
was the 5th targaryen king to sit the
iron round
rolling from 103ac to 129 ac
he succeeded his grandfather the old
king jahiris first
viserys continued the prosperous peace
and legacy of his grandsire
but the seeds for the civil war known as
the dance of the dragon that would much
later engulf the realm
were inadvertently sown in his reign
viserys was a dragon rider who rode
valerian
until the dragon died of old age during
the reign of jaehaerys the first
viserys never bonded with another dragon
after valerian's death
let's get a bit back to explain how
viserys who was not son of a king nor
son of king's eldest son became a king
when king jahiri is the first targaryen
son and air prince amen died in 92 ac
jacarys chose daemon's younger brother
prince balon as his heir
passing over aemon's daughter princess
rhaenys however prince balon died as
well in 101asc
while serving as the hand of the king
leaving behind him two sons
viserys and daemon the old king once
again needed an
heir which again is the first in decline
and unable to choose his new heir after
balon's death
a great council was held in 101ac at
harrenhal to determine who would succeed
him
eamon's daughter reynest was a candidate
as were her children lenore and lena
valerian
but the council ruled in favor of
iseries the first given that he was
balon's heir
and jacharys had favored balon over his
granddaughter rhaenys
and so the old king named viserys hizair
the new prince of dragonstone
and upon the old king's death viserys
became a new king
house targaryen was at its most powerful
during wizards time
having the most members and dragons
since the doom of valyria
viserys was known as the young king when
he ascended the throne
holding a court with queen emma wren the
young king was determined to maintain
the peace and goodwill of his
grandfather jaehaerys the wise
they had a son who died in infancy and
the daughter princess rhaenyra who was
six when her father became a king
the princess became his royal cab bearer
at the age of eight
and was always by her father's side at
feasts balls and tourneys
rhaenyra was dubbed the realm's delight
viserys's younger brother prince daemon
targaryen
one of the most dangerous men in the
seven kingdoms considered himself his
brother's heir
and coveted the little prince of
dragonstone
while viserys loved damon the rogue
prince despite his
flaws he had no wish for daemon to
succeed him viserys was hopeful that his
wife would give him a sun soon
and settle the succession issue viserys
appointed his brother on the small
council but the rivalry between daemon
and the hand of the king sir otto
hightower became
so great that is there is in early 104
ac appointed damon to be commander of
the city watch
to remove daemon from the small council
fearful of daemon becoming a king
otto tried to convince viserys to make
rhaenyra is there
viserys refused as he was confident he
and his wife would one day have a son
emma later became pregnant to the king's
delight in 105 sc
emma died in labor birthing the king's
son and heir
whom there is named balon after his late
father prince balon
but the infant died a day after emma
while the king was mourning his brother
daemon was observed making drunken japes
with his company about the air for a day
when the word of this reached the
grieving viserys his grief turned to
rage
after when the morning period was over
viserys held a lavish ceremony in 105 ac
and had rhaenyra declared the heir and
princess of dragonstone
in response to his ungrateful brother's
ambitions hundreds of lords and landing
knights swore filthy to the princess
and swore solemn oath to defend her
rights of succession
daemon left the capital in a fury
viserys began to groom princess rhaenyra
to be the ruling queen teaching her how
to rule
and made her part of his small council
since viserys was not yet
30 grand maester was the first to urge
him to remarry
and so he did to alice in hightower the
18 year old daughter of seroto hightower
his hand of the king viserys and alicent
married in 106 ac
rhaenyra and alison at first got on well
but that soon changed
when daemon and house valerian fought a
war for control over the stepstones
against the triarchy
the peaceful viserys was unperturbed the
fertile election bore a healthy son
aegon in 107 ac
a daughter helena followed in 109 ac and
another son named eamon was born in 110
ac
the good relations between queen alicent
and princess rhaenyra soon ended
as both desired to be the realm's first
lady
and there could only be one although
alison had given viserys meleers
the king did nothing to change the order
of succession
as he considered the matter already
settled by naming rhaenyra in his will
otto hightower tried to pursue the king
to change his heir from rhaenyra to
aegon
so much that viserys sent him back to
old town bestowing the position of hand
of lionel strong
two parties began to form at court the
queen's party consisted of powerful
lords friendly to alison
and supportive of the riots of her sons
against that was the party of the
princess
those who supported rhaenyra as heir in
111ac a great attorney was held at
king's landing
on the fifth anniversary of viserys's
marriage to allison
during the opening feast queen ellison
wore a green gown
while princess rhaenyra dressed in the
red and black of house targaryen
the note was taken and soon all of
reynar's supporters started wearing
black clothing
while all of alison's followers started
bearing green
over the years the popular names applied
to both factions were inspired by the
colors they wore
rhaenyra supporters were called the
blacks and they got the second
supporters to recall the greens
the attorney also saw the return to the
court of prince daemon
who reconciled with viserys offering him
the crown he claimed
while fighting for the stepstones but
six months later daemon was exiled again
from king's landing
while the grand maester runciter claimed
the two brothers simply got into a fight
it was rumored that daemon took
rhaenyra's virginity and at hand of the
king council the furious king viserys
that daemon should be executed for
treason
septon eustace reminded the council
about the taint of king's laying
thus daemon was exiled instead his there
is hated conflict
and made repeated attempts to seize the
hostilities between the greens and the
blacks
with many fights and false apologies
issued on both sides
he loved his wife and daughter equally
but they only loved each other when he
commanded
so long as viserys ruled peace prevailed
in the seven kingdoms
in 113 ac visayas decided it was time
for his daughter rhaenyra to bed
queen ellison wanted the princess to wed
her eldest son aegon
so he could one day be a king viserys
would not hear of it
as aegon was 10 years rhaenyra's junior
and the two had never got on well
the king and council chose layner
valerian to bed rhaenyra to regain the
friendship between the iron throne and
valerians
rhaenyra have ever protested the match
stating laner would prefer
her half-brothers instead of her
rhaenyra yielded only after viserys
threatened that if she did not accept
the marriage
he would change the succession so in 114
ac a reluctant rhaenyra vets her laner
although it's questioned if the marriage
was ever consummated
lenore spent most of his time on
shriftmark surrounded by handsome
squires
and infrequently visited rhaenyra on
dragonstone
later the same year rynera gave birth to
her first son
jacarius valerian however due to the
babe not having the traditional valyrian
features of either of his parents
lenore and rhaenyra both had light
silver gold hair and purple eyes rumors
spread that the child's real father was
her lover sir harvin strong
the strongest man in westeros called
break bones and rhaenyra's thorne shield
who resided with her on dragonstone
queen ellison bore a third son thereon
to king viserys the same year
viserys got two more grandsons years
later by rhaenyra
lustre is valerian born in 115 ac and
joffrey valeria in 117 ac
all three of rainer's children had pug
noses brown hair and brown eyes
further spreading the belief throughout
the kingdom that the children's real
sire was sir harming strong
the greens were the ones who sparked
this rumor often calling them strong's
prince damon and his wife lena velerion
had twin daughters named bayla and raina
the brothers daemon and viserys
reconciled a second time
and with the blessing of the king
princess rhaenyra betrothed the jacarys
and luceries to bayla and rhina
the year 120ac became known as the year
of the red spring
because of its many deaths and accidents
lena valerian the wife of prince daemon
targaryen died after a failed birth
at her funeral a quarrel broke out
between eamon targaryen and the sons of
rhaenyra
who were accused of being bastards from
house strong
eamonn lost an eye man luceries defended
jacaryus with a knife
the false apologies from the families of
rhaenyra and alice sent fooled no one
but viserys
the king issued an edict that anyone
spreading the strong rumor would lose
their tongue
and ordered sir harvin strong to depart
from dragonstone to herrerhal
afterwards a massive fire at harrenhal
killed harvin and his father lionel
the hand of the king while some blamed
it on the curse of harrenhal
others whispered that daemon lord
corliss velaryon and even viserys were
responsible for the blaze
the king recalled sir auto hightower as
the king's hand
the year also saw the death of
rhaenyra's husband leonard valerian
killed in a fight between his companion
and lover sir carl cory
who many whisper was hired by damon to
do so
rhaenyra and damon shocked the realm by
vetting without viserys knowledge
a huge scandal as neither lena nor
lenore had been dead for six months
it made viserys furious it took some
time before viserys and daemon
reconciled
the year ended with rainer and daemon
welcoming the birth of their first son
prince aegon the younger another son
born in 122 ac was given the name
darius after rhaenyra's father king
viserys himself
rhaenyra sons by daemon and all had
targaryen features
the forced closeness of rhaenyra's
analysis children increased animosity
between the blacks and the greens
the royal children and grandchildren
became dragon riders
and court visitors observed the dragons
of one faction snapping and spitting
flames at the dragons of the other party
viserys died on the third day of the
third moon of 129 ac
during a nap in the red keep of king's
landing on his deathbed he refused to
change the succession
and decorate his heir to be rhaenyra he
was found dead by a servant who first
went to allison
to inform her of wizarus death which
proved to be a grave mistake
as ellison proclaimed aegon the king
over the vicious of his heirs
at the time of her father's death
rhaenyra was on dragonstone
the green sinking's landing ensured that
the news of viserys's death did not
reach her
until her own supporters in the red keep
were dead or imprisoned
and dagon the second coronation had
already occurred
king wizards decreed rhaenyra to succeed
him but aegon the elder the eldest son
of his second wife alice sand was
instead crowned aegon ii
by sir kristen cole the lord commander
of the kingsguard
this led to a civil war between rhaenyra
and aegon the dance of the dragons
the devastating civil war that tore
apart the seven kingdoms
the war lasted for three years and by
the time it came to an
end thousands were dead nearly all of
the targaryen dragons had been killed
as well as many targaryens themselves
king viserys the first will be the main
character in the first season
and upon his death the realm will
explode into a massive civil war between
the blacks and the greens
the targaryen civil war known as the
dance of the dragons
20 major battles even more smaller
battles
and even more betrayals turn cloaks and
twists
all of that and more this game of
thrones prequel show house of the dragon
brings in 2022
let me know your thoughts about
everything the prequel its characters
especially king viserys in the comment
section down below
thank you so much for watching and i
hope to see you in the next one
peace